our musician and our first composition
is by using the truth from UC Texas
roots and so thanks and thanks very much
for inviting me here I very much enjoy
coming to these kinds of
interdisciplinary workshops where you
have people from different communities
speaking and so I knew that I was
talking after lunch so I want to start
with some kind of high-level Sagan keep
us awake I'll do my best and you'll help
me out otherwise right so the rather
than starting with probably on Logic
though I definitely will get to probably
on Logic I want to start at the other
end from the kind of data that I'm
interested in looking at and in
particular that's so abundant these days
where you have very rich multi
relational multimodal spatial temporal
all kinds of crazy data whether you
think of it from you know social media
or something like that or think of it
from IOT smart cities and so on and on
the one hand I want to be able to build
principled inference algorithms for
making predictions from these and I want
to do that in a way that exploits the
information as intelligently as possible
but at the same time I want to raise
caution and have a fair bit of
skepticism about some of the kinds of
predictive models that are currently
being built from this data because this
data is so you know crazy biases noise
and so on that I also want to give us
tools so that we can question the
predictions coming out of these kinds of
models so putting on my machine learning
hat
here's my abstraction of this kind of
data so I start off with this nice
relationally structured data lots of
different kinds of entities and so on
and what I would say most current
predictive analytics and machine
algorithms do is they take this data and
they flatten it and they put it in a
table and they put it in a table where
the columns are attributes or features
the rows are instances and then I'm
going to make predictions on this and
there's a lot of issues with this so
first off just keeping track of even how
I got these values from this richly
structured data is an important piece in
and of itself just the future
engineering involved but one of the most
important things is when you do this
flattening there's typically an
independence assumption being made and
that independence assumption is that
those rows are iid
so independent identically distributed
and a lot of what I'm going to be
talking about in this talk is how do we
mix logic and keeping track of the nice
structure with a parameterization of a
probability distribution that
potentially is richer than just a simple
one and I'll return to this later but I
think there's a fair amount of
connections to the exchange ability that
we were talking about before or
yesterday a fair bit and then I guess
there's another talk tomorrow
that's about exchange ability and I
think these are important ties that
we'll talk more about okay so for my
talk I'm going to give a little bit of
background about statistical relational
learning and kind of a context for some
of
the approaches that have been done
because it's after lunch I'm gonna be
doing a language probabilistic soft
logic I'll start off by doing it by
example so I'll give you some examples
of programs but then the key result in
the one that Dan was very keen for me to
talk about here is a very new result
that we have that has a connection
between work in the randomized
algorithms community with work in the
graphical models community and with
other interpretations for these that
result in a very fast optimization and
then time permitting I'll do a little
bit of a wrap-up that kind of hopefully
make some connections with some of the
things that have been discussed so far
so statistical relational learning so
this was mentioned in the introduction
connections between this community came
up in the AI community and at that time
so the first workshop was in 2000 you
know Stuart gave an invited talk there
the there's been a number of workshops
dog show meetings a burse workshop as
well and there's a number of distinct
approaches that have been developed here
but I want to mention one before I dive
into or mention a couple of them before
I dive into talking about PSL and one of
the early ones who be Pfeffer who will
be here tomorrow Daphne Koller of Stuart
mentioned this probabilistic relational
models that was work some of the work
that I think is actually closest related
to some of the work in probabilistic
databases and I actually think that
there's still a very nice opportunity
for some
cross-fertilization between those and I
will mention that a little bit more at
the end then there's a collection of
approaches that are kind of more
generative so like blog that Stuart was
talking about and then the probabilistic
programming approaches like Church and
so on that we'll hear a lot more about
tomorrow were also developed so Brian
mulch
who's doing the work in blog and several
others and then some of the later work
was around Markov logic network so the
Markov logic Network work has already
been mentioned several times and what
I'm going to present now is something
where syntactically it looks very
similar to Markov logic but then I'm
going to get into the very interesting
differences in terms of interpretations
and especially scalability and so if
you're interested in like all this
historic these different approaches this
is a tutorial that covers a bunch of
them but on to PSL so PSL is a
probabilistic programming language for
defining certain kinds of collective
inference problems which I'm going to
give examples of in a minute where I'm
trying to find joint distributions over
a collection of unknowns given some
evidence and usually that evidence it is
going to be this kind of rich multi
relational social networking
kind of data and like you know many many
approaches and I'm going to use logic
for representing relationships and
properties using predicates I'm going to
have rules and I'll save more precisely
what these are but that captured
dependencies
or constraints so they can be hard
constraints oftentimes in these kinds of
demands you want to talk about
aggregates so you want to talk about the
sets of neighbors of a know that since
so on and so having that kind of in
fundamental in the language is actually
useful but the key difference from this
language and most others is the random
variables are going to be continuous
value so rather than being boolean
binary 0 1 they're going to be a range
from 0 to 1 and then like many things
ESL program is going to be a collection
of rules applied to an input database
then that as I'm going to show sort Li
it's going to define a probability
distribution so let's do this by example
so one of the kinds of problems that we
often want to do is you know we have
some network we're trying to label the
notes and you know timely inference now
we're trying to label them with their
political parties and typically what
happens in these kind of collective
classification problems is you have some
of the nodes where you have observed
labels but you have some other set where
they're unobserved and what I want to
eventually do is get a joint
distribution over all of these unknowns
and so how do I do this again by cartoon
you know first off for a particular node
that I'm trying to make this inference
for I want to use all the local
information I can so if I know something
about the campaign's that they
contribute to well that's a feature that
should go into my model so I should have
something that says well if they donate
to a particular party they're more
likely to vote for a particular party
and I am going to have weights
associated with these I'm not going to
tell you yet what the semantics of these
weights are but
I will show you how you can learn these
weights from data or you can learn them
from data other things you know their
status updates their tweets I can look
at some you know words that are used in
them and say something again about some
local evidence that I think it's more
likely they vote for a particular party
but now the interesting piece is you
know I have this kind of network so I
want to not just use the local
information I want to use things like
well if they're a friend voted for a
particular party they're more likely to
vote for a party if their spouse votes
for a party they're more likely and
maybe I have some sort of relative
weightings that says this maybe is more
informative and then what I want to do
is I want to label these nodes so again
this is a template for the kinds of
inferences that I want to be able to do
another common inference is predicting
relationships so this one's a little bit
richer where I have what does it mean
what's the meaning of the wait so I'm
gonna get to the meanings of the weights
and that's actually gonna be the
important piece so so for now my
problems that I'm gonna do the next two
problems are just supposed to be
motivation what I want to be able to do
so I have some communications and based
on the communications i'm going to infer
the kinds of emails people's own so
maybe they send social emails deadline
emails and so on
then i can say something about well if
they send a certain kind of email then
that may be indicative of the kind of
relationship that people have and then
finally I can have more definitional
so if a is the supervisor of B and the
supervisor of C then the relationship
between B and C is colleagues and maybe
I want to make that hard constraint so I
can given an infinite way and then the
last kind of template for the kinds of
problems that I'm interested in these
were mentioned in earlier talks entity
resolution is very common thing that you
want to do where you have some
references so a and B and I'm trying to
figure out you know are these this John
Smith the same as this J Smith then I
want to use something about the
similarities of the names and say okay
they're more likely to be Co referent
according to some string similarities I
could use a whole bunch of string
similarities here oftentimes you want to
do that I can look at the overlap in
their friends and so this is a nice one
where you get this kind of recursive
dependence you know they're going to be
similar if their friends are similar
their friends are similar if their
friends are similar and so on and
another place where you get that kind of
dependence is this kind of transitive
closure if a and B are the same then
beard and B and C are the same then a
and C are and again you might want to
make this a hard constraint but
oftentimes in the kinds of entity
resolution problems we work on while you
want to make it a high weight constraint
you don't actually want to enforce it so
back to the language and what it means
so we're going to take this collection
of these weighted rules and we want to
make reasoning tractable by mapping them
to a convex optimization and the way
that we do this mapping is interesting
and this result is actually
very new you know just a year and a half
ago or so I think you know we've touched
the tip of the iceberg I think there's
lots of things that can still be done
from this and I'm going to show you
three ways that we get from these kind
of weighted logical rules to the same
convex optimization and that's the thing
that actually very attractive that from
these kind of three sets of assumptions
and three different actual
interpretations or what those continuous
value or zero one between zero and one
valued random variables mean you get to
the same thing and then I'll show some
results on real settings where it works
so I'm gonna actually be flipping back
and forth between a logical
interpretation to the probabilistic
interpretation so bear with me right now
I'm going back to the logical
interpretation of where this is the
simplest possible setting where I have
weighted logical rules of the following
form you know maybe this isn't the
prettiest notation but I'm going to take
these rules that are like what I had
before and then I'm just going to
rewrite this in equivalent clausal form
right so cs101 right
and then I'm going to do what lots of
people do
I'm going to define a probability
distribution where the probability
distribution is proportional to the
exponent of the weighted sum over all of
the rules of these clauses and then I'm
going to be looking at the kind of
inference I'm going to be looking at is
map inference where I want to find the
assignment to the random variables X
then maximize the exponent given I
ground database and so at this point all
of you should be thinking okay it's
after lunch clearly I'm missing
something because she'd just defined max
at you know we know this is
combinatorial this is envy heart so
nothing's happened here but now I'm
going to switch the interpretation so
I'm going to go from the logical
interpretation to alternate
interpretation from randomized
algorithms and I'm going to change the
view of the variables instead to be
rounding probabilities so they're going
to be the probability that I round up to
one or down to zero and so then what I
can do is I can kind of rewrite this so
that I'm looking at the expected score
of a clause and looking at that
expectation and then putting it into the
total X expected score I get the
following and again at this point I'm
saying okay well as you still haven't
done much for me because this is still
horrible
it's non-convex you know this isn't an
easier problem yet
but at this point I'm gonna make use of
a very very old result which Dan may end
up chatting about a little bit more
later but a basic result around having
approximation guarantees for this by
doing some relatively straightforward
rewriting of the probabilities in terms
of the in terms of the expectations and
putting a linear bound on this and the
nice thing is that I've turned this into
something where I now have this linear
form and then on top of it I have a
guarantee for it and so we could get a
3/4 optimal guarantee for the discrete
solution using this ok and again this is
a known result the thing that's
interesting is you know I've taken
something that was come tutorial I now
have a convex problem for solving it but
I can make a connection between this and
approaches that people have done in the
graphical models community for doing
approximations for large Markov random
fields and so actually kind of remember
this general form here
so within the graphical models community
a common approach so common that people
often just say oh it's a linear
relaxation of the Markov random field is
to approximate during the maximum
a-posteriori inference by taking the
kind of complex probability distribution
the joint distribution and basically
relaxing it so that you only abase some
of the constraints in the distribution
and there's there's a big line of work
in doing this but you're basically
trying to find consistent marginals in
some sort of simpler set and so let me
so luckily from earlier talks we've seen
a bunch of factor graphs already but the
way of viewing the weighted rules over
the Joint Distribution of the exes these
fees are the represent the rules either
the local potentials or binary
potentials or you can have higher order
potentials but the grounding out of the
database with the rules defines a large
Markov random field where the thing
that's unusual about these potentials is
they correspond to the logical functions
now from this what we can look for is we
can look for the marginal distributions
now normally when you're doing exact map
you would need to find the marginal
distributions that are consistent with
you know all of the constraints but
oftentimes what one does is one just
looks at the local information and then
finds just the consistency
and so it turns out that if you take and
push do some basic algebraic
manipulation of the overall
representation for this Joint
Distribution then you can actually end
up getting this form for the local
consistency relaxation and this form for
the consistency relaxation is exactly
the same form as what we had for the
randomized map inference and now the
cool thing you know forget whether or
not you're interested in PSL or not this
connection between a bound that was
well-known in this community to this
thing that people were doing in the
graphical models community but didn't
have any bounce for is a important
contribution so these are two of the
interpretations the third one is also
where we started so when we started off
doing probabilistic soft logic we were
very interested in problems where we
were doing these kind of matching
problems where we wanted to like align
ontology is know we wanted to say you
know these things the same as this
relationship the same and then you know
think of the entity resolution problem
that there's a bunch of instance data
that you're trying to match as well and
we started off with having variables
match not match so 0 1 and we tried to
do this using ml ends and I just you
know didn't work at all and so we change
the interpretation so the the random
variables in this setting is are
actually the similarity between things
or alternatively more generally a degree
of truth and these things
and when we did that we were this is the
third interpretation we were using an
interpretation for the rules this is
coming from soft logic there's a bunch
of different logics of people used for
doing this we specifically chose the
Lucas Eve it's logic because this is the
one that gives you a convex function and
so in particular keep them eye on this
that when you convert this to a notion
of distance to satisfaction and again
there's some flips and mins and maxes
going on here but you get this inference
objective and at this point hopefully
this is starting to look familiar this
ends up being the same form as the other
two so we've shown this equivalence
between these three different
interpretations and so it's one
formalism and a set of algorithms which
I'll go into a little bit more detail in
a sec can deal scalably
with these kinds of problems we put this
into something that we generalize a bit
further called a hinge loss Markov
random field the form you know from
before looks like this but now we're
going to turn this into a loss that as
long as this is a linear function will
support it now at this point we're
starting to lose some of the
equivalences so it's still actually an
open problem to continue to show the
equivalences once we generalize this
this way and then the full form ends up
being it's a form of a conditional
random
we have P of Y and then normally we're
conditioning on some X's that give us
this nice form okay and this means that
from a program and some data we get this
out now the question is one more thing
about scaling going to this form so we
can use an off-the-shelf optimizer and
we have used off-the-shelf optimizers it
turns out that instead of solving it as
one big optimization you can actually
make better use of the fine grained
parallelism so I can do something where
I opt amaizing
of these pieces and for this we used a
DMM this is a popular approach for
convex optimization and popularized re
popularized by boyd and it's guaranteed
to converge
now there's other optimization tricks
one could do beyond this but this works
well part of the reason it works well is
because there's this optimization
function has that we're proposing has a
lot of fine grained structure in it and
the fine grain structure ends up having
these simple pieces where most of them
are actually trivially solved so this
ends up being nice so in theory we've
gone from this is a cartoon
combinatorial to something that we can
use an interior point method to
something that we can use a DMM for
here's some results I'll have some more
later on a real problem where you know
we have hundreds of thousands of
potential functions this is something
where ATM the interior point method
takes hours and this is taking seconds
or a minute
so okay but does it work on real
problems briefly compared with discrete
MRF so discrete mrs like ml ends for a
collective classification problem and a
link prediction problem you know I want
this is accuracy this is area under the
precision recall curve the big thing is
you know we're slightly better in terms
of accuracy but you know orders of
magnitude better in terms of speed these
are for small problems for another
flavor problem where we're trying to do
image completion and we can compare to
things like deep belief networks and so
on we're doing a little bit better than
the kind of state of the art and we're
also doing it fast
the quality's better English one color
certain lines the PSS an approximation
of discrete it should be almost as clear
but it seems to be better
what is it would be even better not just
faster well so you had this slide your
closing slide was exactly this this kind
of trade-off between accuracy of the
model and inference and so on there's a
lot more to be teased out here but we
have found that oftentimes we are doing
a better at the problem and so that may
mean that the mln representation wasn't
capturing the problem that well there's
there's a lot to unpack there and
another kind of problem activity
recognition and video again these are
kind of state-of-the-art computer vision
features that are often used and then
what we did with the PSO model is we put
a relatively trivial model on top of it
that had something that essentially says
you know if there's a bunch of people
doing something in a video they're
probably doing the same thing and if
they were doing something in one frame
of the video they're probably doing the
same thing in the next frame unless you
have strong evidence to the contrary and
we get a significant bump up in
performance over the baselines
and then a different kind of problem on
computational biology of drug target
prediction and this is a case where
again we're beating state-of-the-art
and we have done a lot of different
applications and a lot of different
domains normally in a more applications
oriented talk I would go into these more
I think some of the ones that are kind
of interesting are within the
computational social science space we
can actually kind of encode different
competing social science theories for
how people trust each other and then
have a data-driven way of comparing them
the application that I'll mention a
little bit more just given the time some
of the results partly because I think it
highlights a place where there's a mix
of using probabilistic inference
together with logical inference is
knowledge graph construction and this is
basically an information extraction kind
of setting where I can use either just
source statistics or I can add in some
information about entity resolution or I
can add in some ontological constraints
where the ontological constraints are
the things like subsea relationships
domain range and so on now normally
those are intractable to do inference
with but we were able to encode this in
these PSO models and both of these
contribute to doing a better job at
inferring the knowledge and we can do it
fast so compared to the competing ml n
walking to the implementers they said
you know what take a or more to run and
we're running this in like an hour you
paralyze it we're running it in ten
minutes fifteen minutes over you know
millions of X extractions so
hopping up and doing a little bit of
discussion so you have like five minutes
so I'm really excited about PSL
hopefully that came across I'm happy to
talk about it more but in the context of
this workshop I think there's these
interesting opportunities for connecting
work in theory databases probabilistic
databases and the machine learning
community and I think that there's some
interesting differences in motivation
but at the same time I find it
fascinating that there's actually some
core pieces that are similar and I'm
going to speak to it more the place that
I know the best the relationship between
the srl and the probabilistic database
work but some of the places that I see
opportunities are exactly around lifted
inference and so lifted inference I
think we've seen in the talks
Dan's talk this both dance talks this
morning and then this afternoon ghee and
also Wolfgang talked about lifted
inference from a probabilistic database
perspective I think there's also some
techniques from the graphical models
community about lifted inference but
haven't fully been exploited so I think
there's real opportunities there for
more work and one of the places where I
see this is there's a real difference in
the kinds of queries that I as a when
I'm putting my machine learning hat on
wanna do I usually want to do map
inferences or marginal inferences versus
in probabilistic databases they do these
cool inferences that are over richer
kinds of queries so even like I select
project join kind of query where you are
doing a lot more potentially inference
to solve that there's this difference in
how things are parameterised and so the
parameterization of some of the srl
methods are much more at the schema
level and rather than at the data level
and that piece I think can be exploited
and you know one piece of work where we
connected to prm's for doing this is the
following and we actually did you know
connecting to yesterday's some of
yesterday's talks use a form of by
simulation to be able to answer the
lifted inference question but I think
there's there's really rich things to be
studied here structure learning learning
the structure of these rules is
important and I think it connects to
exchange ability open-world semantics
that Stuart mentioned this is a place
where I see the models that I talked
about today were mainly discriminative
they're not generative there's an
interesting kind of opportunity to mix
these I think and I'm happy to go into
this in more detail and then none of
this talks about causality
interpretability explain ability all of
these are hugely important for you to
have confidence in what's coming out and
that is part that goes to what I
mentioned at the very beginning kind of
exploiting being intelligent about how I
can exploit the structure in the data
but then also having some skepticism
about what's coming out of these
predictive models so
and then I want to do my advertisement
for Santa Cruz so we have my colleagues
here we have our redwoods our nice
building our view and then just down
here so so come visit us so you
mentioned we am so on money collection
semi-definite programming there's two
papers that year there's two papers that
year there's two seminal results and
they're actually the same year yeah so
it's not that paper actually a lot of
people because it's beautiful silly but
nothing it was really yeah the end this
is a different paper
dimitra's and I have had this discussion
well so in a weird way
so one interpretation is a relaxation
and then if you go with our original one
which is our soft interpretation that's
an exact result sorry that's interesting
because one of the things that I don't
know that this is exactly this but I
didn't get to talk about learning the
weights and we also allow latent
variables as soon as you put in latent
variables then it ends up being non
convex and we actually have some cool
work for dealing with that case but it
doesn't have quite the same punchline